[Music]
the simple substance of spirit as
consciousness is divided in other words
just as the consciousness of abstract
sensuous being dances over into
perception so also does the immediate
certainty of a real ethical situation
and just as for sense perception simple
being becomes a thing of many properties
so for ethical perception a given action
is an actual situation with many ethical
connections for the former however the
superfluous plurality of properties
concentrates itself into the essential
antithesis of individuality and
universality and still more for ethical
perception which is the purified
substantial consciousness does the
plurality of ethical moments become the
duality of a law of individuality and a
law of universality but each of these
divisions of substance remain spirit in
its entirety if in sense perception
things have no other substance than the
two determinations of individuality and
universality here these determinations
express only the superficial antithesis
of the two sides
paragraph 446 starts the first sub
subsection of the spirit portion of the
phenomenology and it's titled with with
three different things one of the
ethical world right and then we have
human and divine law and then we have
man and woman
why is Hegel focusing on this well the
real conflict here is going to be
between human and divine law running
throughout this section but the family
is going to play a very significant role
in terms of the locus of the divine law
as we're going to see as we move into
further paragraphs and why man and woman
well in part because the family is going
to be understood in terms of the locus
of not just a household but also
reproduction but reproduction also of
brother and sister as we're going to see
I don't want to say too much about that
at this point not least because there's
a lot of ground to cover before we get
there but also because we want to look
here at the very early shapes and
shaping that that's going on on Hegel's
part so he says that the simple
substance of spirit as consciousness is
divided okay this is nothing new in our
entire treatment consciousness the very
nature of consciousness within the
Hegelian
system is to be something that is by you
know being consciousness divided it can
be divided into itself as subject and at
the object of consciousness it can be
divided further in terms of its own self
relation of reflexivity
as self consciousness it can attempt to
try to encompass itself and other self
consciousnesses under laws there's all
sorts of interesting things going on
here Hegel is going to provide us with a
very interesting analogy here that shows
why indeed we wanted to keep
mind the dialectics that we went through
and here he's going to refer us all the
way back to the very first dialectical
process that we went through in the
consciousness section he's going to talk
about the transition from abstract sense
certainty that is certainty that
consciousness possesses of the this the
this the here the now that that presents
itself in seemingly in an unmediated
fashion and what he's going to call the
immediate certainty of the real ethical
situation
look at this height of a I'll use the
word real there that leak is named and
so how are these actually similar to
each other well it has to do with the
process that we're going to go through
which Hegel is just sketching for us at
this point this is what is going to be
happening throughout this this section
and indeed in in some of the other
sections to follow so he says that with
abstract sensuous being right our
conscious of that consciousness of that
passes over into perception var name um
we had a new transition to a second
section you know var damning or the
thing in its properties and what did
perception yield us in our analysis of
consciousness of objects the thing to
ding right and then its many properties
eigen shaft and you know it's its
peculiarities you could also say the
things that belong to it
which can be separated out from each
other and if you remember back there was
an entire dialectic that we traced out
in great detail and and perhaps a little
bit more length than some people might
desire about how these different
properties can be understood as related
to each other and is bearing upon the
thing the thing is in a certain respect
Universal and these are the
individuality with
with in it now he says that just as the
consciousness passes over in this way so
does the immediate certainty of a real
ethical situation of a real ethical
being remember that for Hegel being is
real it has you know actuality but being
per se is not the end story of anything
Spirit is in a certain respect greater
than an encompassing being right it
transcends it and it also sub lanes it
so we begin with an immediate certainty
of some real ethical situation could be
a norm could be a relationship could be
whatever you like in this case we're
going to see him talking about culture
the culture of a particular political
community so he goes on he says for
ethical perception now he doesn't
actually say ethical perception at this
point in the text Miller is reading that
in but but rightly so I think because of
the analogy here he just says food is it
because for the ethical for for you know
what we're talking about here for this
type of consciousness so why not call it
perception actually this is a good point
to say a little bit about why that might
be okay
particularly if you have a mindset that
perception is just of you know something
that you call the empirical and you
understand the empirical in terms of
sense perception right who would be
somebody else in the history of
philosophy that Hegel drew upon who
talks about perception of ethical
matters Aristotle Aristotle in the
politics says that we have perception a
stasis of the good and the bad the
beautiful and the ugly the just and the
unjust be useful and the harmful and all
the other moral qualities katha a lot in
Greek or etcetera
Latin and our English you know
transliteration of that so if this is
not that unique of a position to talk
about ethical perception if we look
ahead to other phenomenologist for
example say mock Schaller or Gabrielle
Marcel this is not a foreign concept to
them either so so we can put that aside
if perception if the word really hangs
you up then substitute another word in
there that that would work just as well
in any case for ethical perception what
is the analog to the thing it is the
situation now what's being translated
here as actual situation is fall des
Honda Honda is you know comportment or
action right fall means case right so
the case of the action the case of the
behavior the case of the comportment the
case of some sort of commitment that's
going on we could talk in terms of a
policy we get to talk in terms of a
crisis we could talk in terms of a
simple action that's being undertaken
but we've got some sort of ethical
situation as Hegel's calling it and it
has as militant strands that have many
connections or we might say many
relations feel a bit zillion ways in
which it is interconnected with with
other things so he says now for the
former that is the thing with many
properties the superfluous plurality of
properties beautiful phrase there
concentrates itself into the essential
antithesis of individuality and
universality Hegel says this is even
more the case for ethical perception
which is the purified substantial
consciousness the plurality of ethical
moments the plurality of different
relations that we could talk about here
becomes the duality of the law of
individuality and a law of you
morality so that's how the laws are
being framed right now we don't yet have
human and divine law on the scene
instead we have a law of individuality
and a law of universality but he says
each of these divisions of substance
remain spirit in its entirety now this
is going to be a really key point that
he's going to re-emphasize at a number
of different places both of the two
moments of spirit encompass spirit or
embodied spirit in its entirety that's
why each one of them can think that it
got the entire market cornered on being
right on having the last word in
relation to the other so what we end up
seeing are quite literally tragic
situations in which these two laws will
have to come into conflict not merely
contact or relation but conflict with
each other so he goes on and he says if
in sense-perception things have no other
substance than the two determinations of
individuality and universality here
these determinations what individuality
and universality express only the
superficial antithesis of the two sides
so there's something deeper than merely
the struggle of the individual against
the universal or the individual again
say the state right or the individual
against the community or the individual
against norms we've actually gone
through the individual versus stuff
quite a bit in earlier dialectics if you
think about it the whole of you know
what followed after the master-slave
dialectic the stoic the skeptic the
unhappy consciousness and then later on
in the reason section particularly with
the three attempts in that middle part
of the reason section you know pleasure
necessity law of the heart virtue in the
way of the world so now we're moving
forward and we're going to actually
we're not going to follow up too much
on this analogy Hegel is using this at
this point to help us see how the
splitting is taking place
in the essence we are considering here
individuality as the meaning of
self-consciousness in general now of a
particular contingent consciousness in
this determination therefore the ethical
substance is actual substance absolute
spirit realized in the plurality of
existent consciousnesses this spirit is
the community which when we enter the
sphere of reason it's practical
embodiment was for us absolute essence
and here he has emerged on its own
account in its truth as conscious
ethical essence and as essence for the
consciousness which here is our object
it is spirit which is for itself in that
it preserves itself in its reflection
and individuals and it is implicitly
spirit or substance in that it preserves
them within itself as after the actual
substance it is a nation as actual
consciousness it is the citizens of that
nation this consciousness has its
essence in simple spirit and the
certainty of itself in the actuality of
this spirit in the nation as a whole
it has its truth therefore not in
something that is not actual but in a
spirit that exists and prevails
now in paragraph 447 Hegel makes a very
important clarification which is going
to lead us along the path ultimately in
a few paragraphs to discussing and
developing the human law and the divine
law as opposed to each other within the
matrix within the fabric you might say
of a real and existing community so he
specifies for us that individuality
which we just saw in the last paragraph
is being played off against universality
in spirit right in in the ethical action
and the ethical perception about the
situation and about all the different
ways in which the situation can be read
the individuality now is as he says to
be understood as self-consciousness in
general and he tells us what does that
mean that means not as a particular
contingent consciousness which we've
looked at quite a bit already in the
past so it's not as if it doesn't have
to do with any particular individuals
but it doesn't have to do with each and
every single particular individual there
are going to be some individuals within
this dialectic who are going to stand
out as paradigmatic you might say and
now which ones are they well you'll have
to look ahead and see which ones we're
actually talking about here we want to
look at what Hegel is developing so he
says in this determination the
determination of individual
individuality self-consciousness he says
the ethical substance is actual
substance the ethical substance what it
is that we have been seeking for we were
doing implicitly earlier in the
consciousness section and the self
consciousness section and then gradually
became more and more aware of in the
reason section and now hopefully we're
going to get our hands forgotten in the
spirit section is actual substance V R
click it is something that has present
has reality in the world so he says it
is absolute spirit realized in the
plural
exist in consciousnesses so the ethical
substance is realized in all of these
other consciousnesses which are
connected with each other these really
ought to be understood as self
consciousnesses of course right and he
says the spirit is the community the
mind reason the the essence of what is
in common you know we use this word
community which we get from latin
without often thinking about what what
it's supposed to signify because it has
you know emotional resonances for us
what is it that we do have in common
well we're not really a community if we
don't share some values and we don't
share some basic comportment some basic
assumptions you know we can talk about
being a community in a metaphorical
sense with a bunch of people thrown
together on a desert island with nothing
in common save for their humanity or
when we're thinking about the ideal of
the liberal nation states where it's you
know supposed to just be totally value
neutral and allow for everybody to you
know live out their life plan so long as
it doesn't interfere with or harm
somebody else right
that's not community that's not
community and the substantive sense that
Hegel is talking about here so what
would be community he says this is the
community which when we entered the
sphere of Reason in its practical
embodiment was for us absolute essence
here has emerged on its own account in
its truth as conscious ethical essence
so this is a now community that is in
some way aware of itself aware of its
own structure its own membership its own
formation what else sets it apart from
other communities or keeps it from
degenerating into non community right
these are all going to be concerns as we
move forward so he goes on and he says
so it's it's conscious ethical essence
and as essence for
the consciousness which here is our
object what is our object well it's
going to be the consciousness of this
entire process so he goes on and he says
it is spirit which is for itself in that
it preserves itself in its reflection in
individuals so the ethical substance in
particular izing itself within
individuals who share in that ethical
substance is for itself if this is the
way in which a community is able to
reflect upon itself and thereby to
actually be a community you know
sometimes Hegel gets its criticized by
people who do sloppy readings of history
as you know advocating some sort of
state in which you know nobody really
gets to step outside their boundaries
and and think outside the box or even as
you know sort of a forerunner to fascism
and that's that's really not the case
not if you think about what he's saying
here and not actually if you look at
other things as well but this should put
the lie to that misrepresentation spirit
is for itself through its members or the
community at least as for itself through
its members and he goes on and he says
it is implicitly spirit or substance in
that it preserves them within itself
again you don't really have individuals
individual human beings without having
all the other stuff that goes along with
it like culture like society like
economic exchange like shared meanings
like institutions like traditions
lacking all of that totally you're going
away from human individuals now he goes
on and he says the actual substance it
is a nation and we've seen Hegel talk
about this quite a lot a folk a
community right people that have
something and in common as then he says
there's actual substance it's a nation
as the actual consciousness
as consciousness for itself of the
community it is the citizens the burger
right the people who are just residents
don't just happen to be there but the
people who actually you know have a
stake in in the community the people who
go back and forth with each other and
you might say they don't just build the
community they constantly rebuilt it so
he goes on and he says this
consciousness has its essence and simple
spirit and the certainty of itself in
the actualities of this spirit that is
in the nation as a whole it has its
truth this is very important for Hegel
has its truth not in something that is
not actual but in a spirit that exists
and prevails and we've seen this
language of existing and prevailing in
the past exits tear to use is here you
know something that has being and that
has validity something that that is
worth something the word here is Galton
you know guilt is the actual verb here
talking about this spirit so there's
this dynamic relationship going on now
here between instantiated community and
actual people living in those
communities
the spirit can be called the human law
because it is essentially in the form of
a reality that is conscious of itself in
the form of universality it is the known
one and the prevailing custom in the
form of individuality it is the actual
certainty of itself in the individual as
such and the certainty of itself as a
simple individuality is that spirit as
government its truth is the authority
which is openly accepted and manifest to
all a concrete existence which appears
for immediate certainty in the form an
existence that is freely issued forth
here in paragraph 448 Hegel now brings
up this term human law and gives us our
first development of this this concept
that's going to prove very important
it's only one-half of the two sides of
the law that are going to be you know
mixing in with and and suppressing and
and you know sub leading and and
conflicting with each other throughout
the rest of this section but right now
we want to focus just on this he hasn't
brought up the divine law yeah
and Hegel says that what we've just
discussed right this relationship
between the individuals and the the
community the nation is going to be
understood now in terms of the human
life as this spirit can be called that
that is a human law because it is
essentially in the form of a reality
that is conscious of itself so it's a
reality it's a very excited something
that is actual and it is also conscious
of itself it is conscious of itself
remember through its membership right
and the consciousness that they have
we're going to see a particular member
or a set of members assume a greater
importance in just a moment so he says
in the form of universality so if we're
thinking we're sort of working our way
through this consciousness of it what
are we conscious of when we're conscious
of the human law as subjects for example
or as those you know modifying
legislating and acting enforcing the law
we're aware of a sign of universality
and a side of individuality on the side
of universality
we have Hegel says two things he's that
thing that's exhaustively but he is he
is distinguishing these known law but
gotten it this is the canta right so
it's it's something that we do in fact
know you know one of the traditional
attributes of laws that has to be
promulgated
have to be able to to have some
opportunity to know what the law
actually says this is something that we
do see very early on as a matter of fact
some of the early law codes that we have
we do possess them because they were
promulgated and then we have the
prevailing custom now the word for that
is vitta
the very word that we get Villa kite as
you know the ethical from in in this
entire section so this is not a custom
just like well you know when you blow
your nose you should use a handkerchief
and then throw it away or you know hide
it or something like that that's more
that could fit under it is etiquette
right those are what we call little
morals to use an old-fashioned phrase
but what we're talking about here are
the norms that govern a community
sometimes they're not actually spelled
out in written or known or promulgated
law but they're more or less assumed and
Hegel uses this term that's being
translated here as prevailing is for
hondana it is it is they're available
you might say for the the community
members to draw upon so this is the
universal side then we have the
individual sign and now notice what
Hegel does here he doesn't say well the
individual side is the subject who is
therefore aware of this no because law
and custom always requires something of
what we might call an executive function
there has to be somebody to actually
enforce and in many cases to interpret
the law and so Hegel talks here about in
the form of individuality it is the it
is the actual certainty of itself in the
individual as such in in what individual
in the individual who rules
he says the certainty of itself of the
simple individuality is that spirit as
government a year long in in German
which is a little bit closer to you know
the center
rulership
with some you know an old-fashioned term
that we used to have for this Magister
Magister to you right the magistrates
were the people who are enforcing the
laws and you do need to have somebody
doesn't necessarily have to be some sort
of you know all-powerful Hobbesian
sovereign but you do have to have
somebody who actually is making sure
that this stuff gets followed and
enforced and indeed even promulgated
right or taught so the government is
also part of this he says it's truth is
the authority which is openly accepted
and manifest to all that's an ideal of
course there's often contestation within
the government but you notice that we
can make a fundamental distinction
between the universal side and a
individual or a particular side and both
of these are needed and both of these
are what we're aware of when somebody
talks about you know living in a police
state and they're not actually living in
a real police state but something that's
rather a regime that they don't
particularly like because say policing
is being done arbitrarily or being
directed more towards some people than
towards others they're not just talking
about a you know sort of over arching
structure or mentality they're also
talking about the people who are
involved in doing it the people who make
the decisions who exercise discretion on
the ground you might say you know you're
going to jail you're not we could say
the same thing about all the other
functions of government including
education right so he goes on and he
says it is a Thor 'ti openly accepted
and manifest to all you can point at it
and say those are the people in charge a
concrete existence which appears for
immediate certainty in the form an
existence that is freely issued for now
eagle is not worried at this point about
you know the nitty-gritty of well how
did they get power anything like that
he's just saying look in communities
where there is this dynamic that's going
on that we just spelled out in the last
paragraph we do have these two sides to
human law this is all something that is
you might
say manifest this is something that you
can look at something where there may be
some backroom deals but at least you
know who went into that back room that's
not going to be the case quite so much
with the next law that we're going to
turn to
confronting this clearly manifest
ethical power there is however another
power the divine law for the ethical
power of the state being the movement of
self conscious action finds its
antithesis and the simple and immediate
essence of the ethical sphere as the
actual universality it is a force
actively opposed to individual being for
self and is an actuality in general it
finds in that inner essence something
other than the ethical power of the
state
now in paragraph
1:49 Hagel introduces another law a
divine law which is going to oppose
itself to and you might say slip the
bounds of the human law that we've just
begun charting out in the last paragraph
he says confronting this clearly
manifest ethical power this is this is
something that's aboveboard that
everybody can see everybody can to some
degree participate in at least by
understanding and obeying it if not
necessarily by shaping it and applying
it there is a another power the divine
law which is going to rise up against it
he says the ethical power of the state
and there's a nice phrase right the vid
Lika shots mocked right the the capacity
for the state the power of the state you
know state here understood as that which
is driving the community so we have the
you know the community and then we have
the government itself as we talked about
the ethical power of the state winds up
he says because it's the movement of
self conscious action it finds it
antithesis AG Aegon's on something
that's opposing it in what in the simple
and immediate essence of the ethical
sphere a little abstract at this point
and I actually want to keep it abstract
I don't want to try to comment on it too
much and explain it too much because
there's going to be a lot of that going
on in the paragraphs to follow but keep
in mind then what he is saying here is
that area we have something outside of
the bounds not outside of the bounds of
the community but you might say surging
up within it as not fully covered not
fully encompassed by the you know the
ethical power the ethical range
of the community we have something here
that almost sounds you know in some
respects Kierkegaard Ian doesn't fit if
you know your how Kierkegaard was
objecting to Hagel in terms of the
religious versus the ethical I don't
want to go too far with that either at
this point because it is something a bit
different going in but it's worth
signaling so he says that it has actual
universality it is a force actively
opposed to individual being for self the
individual being for self that happens
within the realm of the state whether it
be the individual being for self of the
citizen the burger or the individual
being for self of the government the
right your own right he says and his
actuality in general it finds in that
inner essence something other than the
ethical power of the state so what we've
got going on here is in essence the the
typical Hegelian dialectic of self
authoring of repelling self himself and
some sort of determinate negation
occurring here he doesn't use that term
but this is part of the logic of what is
happening and now we have to chart this
out